Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Los distintos ecosistemas prósperos
del planeta pueden parecer permanentes,
pero en realidad son
vulnerables al colapso.
La jungla puede convertirse en desierto,
y los arrecifes en rocas sin vida,
incluso sin mediar cataclismos,
como volcanes y asteroides.
¿Qué hace a un ecosistema fuerte
y a otro débil cara al cambio?
La respuesta, en gran medida,
está en la biodiversidad.
La biodiversidad está compuesta
por 3 elementos interrelacionados:
la diversidad de los ecosistemas,
la diversidad de las especies,
y la diversidad genética.
Cuanto más entrelazadas
están estas características,
más denso y resistente
se vuelve el tejido.
Analicemos la selva amazónica,
una de las regiones
más biodiversas del planeta
por sus complejos ecosistemas,
por su enorme mezcla de especies,
y por la variedad genética que
hay dentro de esas especies.
Estas son lianas enredadas,
que trepan del suelo
del bosque al dosel,
se entrelazan con las
copas de los árboles
y forman gruesos tallos de madera
que sostienen árboles altísimos.
Ayudados por las lianas,
los árboles dan semillas, frutos
y hojas a los herbívoros,
como el tapir y el agutí,
que diseminan sus semillas por todo
el bosque para que puedan crecer.
Millones de insectos comen el sobrante
y descomponen y reciclan los nutrientes
para crear un suelo rico.
La selva es un enorme sistema lleno de
muchos sistemas más pequeños, como éste,
cada uno repleto de
especies interconectadas.
Cada eslabón le da
estabilidad al siguiente,
fortaleciendo la ola de biodiversidad.
Ese tejido se ve reforzado
por la diversidad genética que hay
dentro de las especies individuales,
que les permite enfrentar los cambios.
Las especies sin diversidad
genética por su aislamiento
o por bajo número de su población,
son mucho más vulnerables
a fluctuaciones causadas
por el cambio climático, enfermedades,
o la fragmentación del hábitat.
Cada vez que desaparece una especie
por su reserva genética debilitada,
se desata un nudo y se desintegran
partes de la red.
¿Qué pasaría si tuviéramos que
eliminar una especie de la selva?
¿Se desmoronaría el sistema?
Quizá no.
El volumen de especies,
su diversidad genética,
y la complejidad de los ecosistemas
forman una biodiversidad
tan rica en esta selva
que la brecha de una especie en
el tejido no lo hace desmoronarse.
La selva puede seguir resistiendo
y recuperarse del cambio.
Pero eso no es cierto en todos los casos.
En algunos entornos, eliminar
solo una componente importante
puede socavar todo el sistema.
Veamos los arrecifes de coral,
por ejemplo.
Muchos organismos de un arrecife
dependen del coral.
Éste brinda microhábitats clave,
y una base de refugio y cría
a miles de especies de peces,
crustáceos y moluscos.
Los corales también crean relaciones
interdependientes con hongos y bacterias.
El coral en sí es un telar
que hace posible el tejido de la
enmarañada red de biodiversidad.
Eso convierte al coral
en un organismo clave,
del que muchos otros dependen
para sobrevivir.
Entonces ¿qué ocurre cuando las
prácticas de pesca destructivas
contaminan y acidifican los océanos
debilitando o incluso matando al coral?
Exactamente lo que imaginan.
La pérdida de esta especie clave implica
la pérdida de sus dependientes, también,
amenazando a toda la estructura
del arrecife.
Los ecosistemas, las especies
y la diversidad genética
juntos forman una trama compleja
y enmarañada de biodiversidad
vital para la supervivencia
de los organismos terrestres.
Los humanos también somos
parte de esta trama de biodiversidad.
Con solo perder algunas hebras,
nuestro propio bienestar
estará amenazado.
Cortemos demasiados eslabones,
y arriesgamos a que se desmorone todo.
El futuro es impredecible
pero la biodiversidad puede
darnos una póliza de seguro,
la propia red de seguridad terrestre
para salvaguardar nuestra supervivencia.